oh that's not in focus that is there we
go hey everyone I will honor and welcome
to my channel where today I'm doing
another anonymous Q&A for hitting two
hundred and eighty thousand subscribers
I was actually supposed to do this for
two hundred seventy five thousand
subscribers but I am late because I am
bad at this basically whenever I do
these I just leave my tumblr inbox open
with anonymous on and then I post a link
on Twitter for about ten minutes before
I take it down I don't generally use
tumblr I just use it for this really but
I'm gonna answer all of these questions
in order and the only ones that I've
removed are ones that are repetitive is
in multiple people asked the same thing
that I've answered a million times
before or that I have no interesting
answer to the first one just says you
eat so yep second question would you
ever consider dating a fan it kind of
depends what kind of fan if it's someone
who knows my walk and likes it but still
views me as an equal or a peer then sure
that's fine by me but if it's someone
who would put me on a pedestal or want
to date me because of my work rather
than because they know me as a person
then of course not because that would be
a very false relationship and I think
power dynamics would be way off there's
little that appeals to me more less than
dating someone who I would have complete
power over because they wouldn't want to
lose me because of my job or my status
that sounds like a nightmare would you
ever do a playboy shoot like Naomi from
IGN did no I guess I should never say
that but maybe one day I would but the
reason I say no as confidently as I did
is because I'm super uncomfortable in
front of cameras no one come to with the
idea of a playboy shoot or like with the
clothing that's required for a shoot
like that or anything like that I'm
totally fine with all of that stuff and
I'm in support of women doing that I
just feel really awkward in front of a
still camera completely fine doing
videos obviously but anytime I have to
like hold a pose I hate it and I'm
pretty sure I always have did you know
your voice lines were going to be used
in gears 5 well I knew that I recorded
for years 5 and I knew that I would be
in the game somewhere but I recorded a
lot of lines for a bunch of different
things and I didn't know which ones they
would use well it's the most best
compliment a fan / follow I ever gave
you not any creepy ones of course you
have to specify like I would pick a
creepy one the best compliment I've ever
received from a
man I don't know if that's the right
word it was when I walked on radio in
Australia I was hosting little
co-hosting be the correct one a show on
triple z about video games and we had a
listener write in who was blind who said
that the way that we spoke about video
games helped him understand them and
picture what they looked like and that
was I don't know one of the few moments
where I felt like what I do actually
matters I really love video games that's
why I'm in the field that I'm in but
it's often hard to feel like it's
important or that it can have a positive
impact on people when it's just such
like a enthusiasts press type thing
how much upkeep does your silver hair
require very little I mean I have to get
it my roots died we call it regrowth in
Australia I have to get that done the
same rate that you would have to get it
done for any hair color and then I just
use a silver tone of shampoo called
finola no yellow every time I wash my
hair it's not hard to use you leave it
in for like less than a minute
people always always like how do you get
yeah colour what's what's the upkeep
what's the dye color that you use it's
all just that shampoo that's it most
underrated fun House member
everyone at fun house works very hard I
don't think there's a single person on
that team who's a letdown where is it
like every other company I've worked at
admittedly they're all a lot bigger
there's always one person or a few
people that you're like just doesn't do
anything but I will say probably Matt
Pete and OMA I think people don't quite
know what they do and thus probably
there's no way that you could fathom how
much they contribute to fun house
literally functioning hey Ilana what are
some things you want to achieve before
30 it's my birthday a few weeks ago I'm
now 26 I only got four years left I just
want to buy a house that's it that's the
only thing buy a house buy I'm 30 I have
no idea if it's possible will you ever
get back into cosplay or try a hand out
at modeling something like Meg Turney or
Jessica Nigri maybe I never got out of
cosplay I just kind of ran out of time
for it I've been meaning to do a Syria
cosplay for forever I've been meaning to
do redo my Supergirl forever so yeah I'm
totally willing to do those again the
last time I cosplayed was only last year
it wasn't like forever ago
Megan Jessa both extreme
talented at what they do and have made
some amazing stuff but when it comes to
their style of modeling again I just
feel weird in front of camera I don't
feel uncomfortable in a bra it's just
the act of taking the photos that I
don't I really don't like it I just
don't want to do it it's just not it's
just not me excellent follow-up question
once your bra size depends on the brand
dog that [ __ ] varies
what's one hidden gem game not including
not including Deadly Premonition you
think everyone should play I don't even
think deadly permissions a hidden gem
that game is pretty much a cult classic
I would say meais Mata which is not
inherently good but does some very smart
things that I think other games probably
should have won from like triangulation
gods we'll be watching for similar
reasons RNG but my main answer not that
much of a hidden gem
it was Capcom Dragon's Dogma doctor
risen I just love that game so are you
dating someone right now what I am yes
how do you feel about the layoffs do you
feel worried about your job or do you
think that you are pretty safe for
anyone who doesn't know this is in
reference to layoffs at roosterteeth
recently
I mean layoffs are awful I reached out
to a whole bunch of people when that
happened you know just asking how they
are it's a very sad thing for anyone who
got laid off obviously I don't feel like
there's anything else to really add to
that I am not at all worried about my
job all the jobs of anyone else at one
house again beautiful job of these
questions coming in orders that are
related the next question is how long do
you see yourself working at funhouse
it's a really good question to ask
something I have no idea I have no plans
to leave finance but I have no idea what
the future holds I eventually want to I
think end up in narrative designing
video games which would mean not working
at fun house for the rest of my life but
yeah my genuine answer is I don't know
that car I don't have a timer on it
there are any game franchises or
companies in general that you would like
to do voice work for listen if there's a
new fable game and I am NOT in it I will
ride it you chase chickens you're just
gonna stand there like a lemon is it
difficult to date because of your fame
like did guys get jealous if you get a
lot of attention when I first started
getting some kind of online attention I
did have a couple of people I was dating
that didn't like
it but since then I have only dated
other people who have following so
that's not an issue at all what has been
your favorite game of the year so far
Sakura Resident Evil 2 I think controls
pretty incredible yeah Mari make it 2-0
I don't know dude I have played a lot of
video games this year but I think Sakura
it's probably winning for me right now
what tattoos do you have when did you
get your first one I'm not going to
detail all of them seems personal I
don't know whatever my first one is the
bat symbol I have on the back of my neck
which I got in my boyfriend at the times
kitchen when I was 16 or 17 which sounds
like a terrible idea but I loved that
tattoo I have zero regrets it was almost
a decade ago over a decade ago and I
still adore it
oh so no heya voicing gives 5b Congrats
by the way thank you
are you looking to show your voice
talents you know the roles are they in
or out of video games thanks for being
such a badass entertaining and
all-around amazing individual thank you
this is very nice coming yes I am in
another game called off to potty that's
coming out later this year in that game
my roles are a lot more significant than
they are in games five where I'm just
NPCs and off the potty I'm actually
still NPCs but quest givers I play named
characters and then there's another
pretty big game next year that I have a
part in that I am not allowed to talk
about yet there are a couple of others
that I've like had discussions about but
nothing is recorded or set in stone or I
haven't signed anything but it's
definitely something I want to do more
of what do you wish your fans did more
of or less of more of watch videos until
the end watch time on YouTube means
everything I'm gonna have to give this
video a dumb headline that will get it
in the recommended feed in order to get
it to get any views and if people just
watched video for longer amounts of time
I wouldn't have to worry about that
stuff just that honestly for the most
part the word fan implies that people
are incredibly supportive and kind and
that is 100% my experience what would
you say is your proudest achievement
final so far there have been some videos
that I made that I really really loved
for like ones that I produced like The
Dream's video that just went up last
week or this weekend maybe I loved that
video it was just an idea that I had
when I was playing around the game that
I thought would be really fun
then we got everyone in to do it and
while I was watching the edit of that
video and giving notes I was laughing
the whole time so it's just like the
little moments that I find really
uplifting and it's very cool to see when
an edit I made or something that I like
put together organizers received really
well by however many people who watch
that video so there's a lot of like
little moments of pride rather than any
dramatic moments of pride are you aware
of how pretty you are
so you can't answer this quiz one's a
trap I imagine this is the same way
everyone else feels but there are days
where I can see myself and and think I
look good it's pretty uncommon but there
are days where I'm like I feel good
about the way that I look today I like
my outfit I like my hair like my makeup
whatever for the most part I actually
don't think about the way that I look at
all and then there are days where I
think that I look awful
just don't spend a lot of time thinking
about my appearance because I don't
value it very much I think there's a lot
more value in being smart or educated or
nice or funny or whatever else so
appearance has never been terribly
important to me sometimes I feel like I
should put more effort into my
appearance because I walk on camera
people will call me out for looking bad
pretty regularly but I just don't okay
it's I'm not a model we've been over
that I'm just here to talk about video
games man what is one aspect of American
culture that you hate well no matter
what I answer people are gonna get mad
about this the people are probably gonna
get extra mad about what I'm about to
say I really hate how Pot is in America
is basically it feels like there are
Republicans and there are Democrats and
there's a left and a right and they
[ __ ] hate each other so passionately
and instead of the political or even the
social climate being about I believe
this and as a result of that I think
that this is the best for most people
and and this is the best for our society
it seems like a constant battle about
who is winning and I find that
inherently very toxic for it to be a
fight about like haha my side one [ __ ]
all of the other side just seems very
anti
people when anal be less gross if who
was purple instead of brown well no
because then we would register that who
was purple and that color would have
that association but I don't want that
to happen as purple is my favorite color
so can you not hey what are you most
excited about for next gen do you think
stadia will actually be able to compete
with the PC / console I am not excited
about next gen raits racing they'll be
more of that and that's great I like
rate racing I know I'm not excited about
the position videogames are in at all
right now and I do want to put together
a feature about this at some point I
think that we are headed in a direction
of subscription services exclusively
which means that publishers will want to
push more games to service games which
we've already seen the start of and less
single-player experiences and that's not
just a thing I'm making up that's
literally in that quarterly
presentations so I'm not excited about
the state of video games right now but
we'll see what annoys you the most when
you go on dates if I have put effort
into like the way that I look and
dressing up and showing up and like
going somewhere nice to dinner and I
feel like I am sitting there in silence
because a guy is on Twitter or texting
that always feels like such a slight to
me and it's happened a bunch of times
because then also to everyone else who's
at whatever restaurant or whatever else
we're doing they're just seeing me just
sitting there like not doing [ __ ]
anything waiting for a dude to stop
looking in his social media how do you
handle the constant negativity from
people that only wish you ill well I've
had my fair share of hate and struggled
to push past it I do my best to model
myself off to you you always seem to
manage a situation with poison just
shrug off the negativity I just make fun
of it it's very rare that I find a
comment that annoys me and I would still
think about it after even 10 minutes
pretty much never happens actually I
generally just will make a joke out of
it and then move on because they don't
mean anything who [ __ ] kicks burgers
or pizza or burritos I am down for all
of those varies depending on my mood
this year I've probably had more
burritos than the other two but for the
most part I would say I probably
choose pizza I love all three of them
and the last question is why are you so
quiet in drunk Mario maker - I don't
remember being quiet during that stream
but the video went up this weekend I
think and if I had to guess I'm just
generally a bit quieter in a group
setting like a larger group especially
when other people around me are being
really loud I don't like being the
center of attention I don't people never
believe that because I walk on camera
but it's very different when you're in a
social setting
alrighty that is it for me today
everyone I have loads more videos coming
out on the channel this week though I've
got myself reacting to playing use v and
hearing my own voice tomorrow and then
the day after that I think I'm going to
upload first minecraft video we played
minecraft with a bunch of food from fun
house and Jon Risinger from roosterteeth
and some of the inside gaming team and
Bruce so I think I'll have that up this
week a part 1 of 2 of that so stay tuned
thank you all so much for all the new
subscribers we've gotten this year I
really appreciate it I will see you guys
next time